je crois que ça a été un lchage
médiatique immérité j'ai rien fait de
mal nulle part à
[Musique]
personne mais je supportais plus un
moment les articles au journaliers j'ai
une famille comme tout le monde tris
enfants quand même d'un certain âge
c'est plus des bébés et neu petits
enfants qui ont entre 22 et 30 et c'est
pas forcément agréable de voir tous les
jours dans le journal local ou national
des contreevérités donc je m'exprimerai
pas longtemps sur ce dossier étant donné
que j'ai demandé enfin que mes avocats
ont demandé à ce que le rapport soit
annulé et contesté parce que pour le
moment la défense que je devrais
représenter je suis au courant de rien
le seul vous êtes tous plus au courant
que moi moi je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'un
comportement inapproprié à l'égard d'une
femme selon vous et qu'est-ce que
constitue un comportement de harcèlement
sexuel je sais pas ce que c'est je pas
fait sait
rien approprié dire que quelqu'un a une
jolie robe est-ce que c'est grave
aujourd'hui oui les temps ont changé moi
j'ai 82 ans euh petit à petit les temps
ont changé ça se dit plus faut faire
très attention plus atttention
aujourd'hui qu'il y a quelques années
c'est
bien donc pour vous un comportement de
harcèlement sexuel c'est dire à une
femme qu'elle a une jolie
robe vous trouvez que c'est uncement
sexuel de dire ça non je vous pose je
vous pose la question monsieur le Gret
je voudrais savoir jusqu'où ça va pour
vous et si c'est le fait de dire à une
femme qu'elle a une jolie robe pour moi
non pour vous peut-être
pour vous monsieur leet est-ce que
demander à une jeune femme de se mettre
en jupe pour voyager est un comportement
approprié c'est je ne réponds pas à
cette question d'une manière
générale je je n'ai pas répondre à cette
question parce que je vous vois venir